hey everybody this is International
master David proofs for chest comm and
today you're going to learn an important
strategy which is how to prevent your
opponent from castling now the reason
why you would prevent your opponent from
castling is because then their king
would be stuck in the center and you
could attack it all game long or all
game short hopefully but that is the
subject for some other videos which we
also have so first things first you need
to learn how to prevent your opponent
from cancelling and then you can go
check out some videos about how to
finish off their King so here is the
most obvious but also not the best way
to prevent your opponent from castling
kingside you can kamikaze sacrifice on
f7 and there's a couple other variations
of how you could do that how you could
sack something in a way that forces
there came to capture and and then not
be allowed to castle but this is the
simplest right if you just bring your
bishop out straight like this your
opponent will probably play good
developing move with their knight you
know attacking your pawn and controlling
the center and you can just play this
terrible move Bishop takes f7 and once
their King has moved they can't cancel
anymore however this is completely
ill-advised because after you play this
and this and castle and they play the
ship's e5 you don't really have any kind
of attack your opponent has far more
pieces in the game and he's preparing to
move his rook to one of these two
squares and then put his King in the
corner at which point he'll really be
laughing so the idea of taking on f7 it
comes up but you don't want to do it in
a totally bad kamikaze kind of way here
is a slightly better way to do it that
does come up like this from a Kings
gambit this is a very aggressive opening
but here you can sack your Bishop and
you've got much better chances than
before because you're already preparing
a pretty strong attack and there's a
variety of examples in the King's gambit
where that happens but now let's turn to
something more serious really than
material sacrifice
so here you are as black-and-white is
threatening to capture a pawn on c6
right so you could just play Bishop d7
to defend it or you could take on d4 but
one strategy you can do in chess is
sometimes to ignore your opponent's
threat if you see sort of a counter that
you can do so in this position black
could just castle and um now white will
take take take take and grab his extra
pawn while attacking your Brooke and
pawn which looks potentially dangerous
for black but what black realized was
that they were slightly ahead in
development if they sacked the pawn on
c6 and that in this resulting position
they could sack more material and
prevent white from castling kingside as
compensation for that so what black
plays in this position is Bishop to a6
and you cut white off on this diagonal
now if he had you know his knight or
bishop on the Kings side they could
probably deal with that problem by
blocking on e2 right but in this case
it's going to be extremely challenging
for white to try to castle this game so
that is a technique and the sample game
about attacking strategy with King stuck
in the center starts from this position
so you can see more about this position
in that other example so cutting off the
diagonal is a good way to keep the King
from castling now here's another good
way to keep a king from castling and
that is to open the e-file
sometimes it's hard to get control of
this diagonal from the very very
beginning right this would be like what
we saw before trying to grab this
diagonal sometimes it's hard to get full
control that diagonal early on in the
game because they can block or they can
even just fight back with their pieces
another important technique to try and
stop a king from castling is to try and
score a check on him by opening up the
main file so here the placement of
black's knight and queen allows white to
strike with a very strong move Knight to
d5 black has to trade and now White has
the file open and so the game continued
like this now white develops the bishop
and
connexes rooks and so even though black
controls the e 1 square white now has
two rooks here and so he's going to make
a sacrifice of a rook to keep the black
King stuck in the center and that is a
famous technique because this is from a
game played by Bobby Fischer and that's
a really good one to keep in mind now
let's show another thing which is
combining the two this is from Paul
Morpheus play in this position he
combines opening the diagonal to keep
the King from castling legally and
opening the e-file to make check attack
threats immediately on the King and that
works really well in positions where
your opponent might try and block on 87
so he starts with E 5 after black's bad
move Knight f6 which just walked into
this a 5 move and black takes and more
if he puts his Bishop on a3 preventing
the King from castling and black is in
dire trouble at this point and the game
continued like this with Queen b3
threatening checkmate on f7 King d7
Queen e6 mate so blacks act upon and in
this position takes like this and I
forget which rookie put on e 1 in this
position but I think you get the idea
that he's using this diagonal Plus this
file to keep the King from castling and
to jumpstart a brutal attack now one
more example of trying to score a quick
check if you can score a check that your
opponent can't capture or block they're
going to have to move their King that's
the only other way to get out of check
and that is going to keep their King in
the center so what should white play in
this position here well absolutely white
should take on d5 with the knight
even though it strengthens blacks
slightly weak pawn on e4 because after
Knight takes Knight pawn takes Knight
Bishop b5 check the black King will now
not be able to castle he'll defend by
blocking with the bishop you'll take it
he'll take it and now his King is a
target and white is going to attack with
Queen before rook c1 and finally another
way to prevent your opponent from
castling this one comes up the least but
I'm still going to mention it is to
displace their rook if you can make your
opponent move the rook then you prevent
castling at least to that side so in
this position from opening theory white
plays d5 even though black has the
seemingly very strong counter d5
attacking the bishop and improving
blacks development but now white takes
takes and he can capture on g7 and this
means black will not be able to Castle
kingside so white has prevented black
from castling to that side by attacking
the rook so those are your important
techniques for preventing castling
capturing on f7 or some other Square
where the King has to recapture himself
and then he can't castle taking a
diagonal that cuts the King off by
controlling one of the squares he needs
to castle through scoring a check on the
King that causes him to move and thus
keeps him from ever castling or
displacing the rook so that it will be
illegal to move to castle onto the side
where the rook has moved I hope you
enjoyed this video and I'll see you
around on chess calm